Contributing to the campaigns and
then they scratch each other's backs.
If the resident were to go in and say,
I'm gonna get rid of all lobbyists,
that president would not
make it through his term. Um,
well it's hard to say that. No, it's not.
No, this is too much money, Joe. I mean,
I know if I'm going to agree
with you in this day and age,
it's hard to say that because you'd have
to get everybody on board with killing
a president. I think they
definitely did it with Kennedy. Oh,
you mean I think a hundred percent you
know, I was talking to, uh, you know,
do you have to get everybody Bowers?
No,
but do you have to get everybody on board?
Yeah,
I mean it just to get everybody on board
who knows about it because otherwise
people are going to tell if you,
if you go and kill the fucking president,
you have to get a lot of
people on board as what we're,
we're probably going to get raided
by the secret service right now.
But I'm saying if you want to kill
president, it's not like it used to be.
I think it used to be less consequential.
Not that it was always,
I mean like John Wilkes booth days, right.
Way Easier to kill the president then.
Then Kennedy ways year to kill a president
in 1963 then is to kill the president
in 2019 could you still do it? Yeah,
but you're probably going to get caught.
Like you would probably get caught.
It let you would have to have,
I mean there would have to be all,
you would have to have a tiny,
small circle of fucking sociopaths and
psychopaths and they all agree to keep it
hush. To me, it's just one person
calling another person saying, do this,
pay him off and then you can get caught.
But one per look be of secret service.
You have a military protecting them yet
it's different cause you'd have to take
some layers to get past all that,
you know,
and someone would have to
make a mistake and mapping.
That was one of the things I said about
a Dealey Plaza and they rolled Kennedy
through.
They like what fucking security person
would ever agree to let someone roll
through with a convertible with
buildings all around. Yeah.
And then also you have to take that long,
slow turn where you know it's sounds
you just drive by going 50 miles an hour
and you've gotta get your gun and shoot
him quick. No, the guy was driving slow.
It's ridiculous. It's like you're
asking for someone to get assassinated,
but I just,
I just really feel like there are rules
like that will never ever know about,
but once you get in there they're like,
hey, here's what you need to know.
Here's what you need to
know not to go against.
I would think that if anybody's
going to tell us that it's Trump,
I think the best thing that could ever
happen is that Trump gets out of his
terms in the White House and just
starts talking. It starts writing plugs.
Tell us then, yeah, you want to
be the king of the world. Right.
A fucking huge book on exactly what it's
like the day you become the president.
That would be insane.
How?
How do you think he's going to be
treated once it gets out though?
They'll love him. You think so?
They love Bush. People hated Bush.
They called Bush a war criminal. Now
he's an adorable grandpa. Paints. No,
it's true. It's true.
It's true. Look Man, what?
Whatever you hate Obama
when he was in office,
they're going to love
him within a few years.
I mean most people that were
supporters of Obama, they love him now.
I mean he's like a,
he's a uh Huh. Yeah, I,
I mean, I don't know. I
think they're going to,
I think a certain percentage of the
population loves Trump right now, period.
And you know they have reasons to back
it up in terms of like the economy,
what they think is
happening with job creation,
all these different things that he's
doing that may or may not not have
devastating implications
depending on who you talk to.
That's an expert and I'm not one. Yeah,
me neither. But there's obviously,
and then also people say,
wow,
this is a trend that was actually going
on during the Obama administration.
He's just riding the wave. Maybe I'm too
stupid. I don't understand that stuff.
But I'm saying there's,
in terms of numbers,
it's not like the country is
completely imploding right now. I mean,
maybe some people buy
some people's metric.
It's not doing as well as he would
like to pretend it is probably.
But my thing is.